What kind of
upside is it? That's
what started to be
tricky. Yes, it's impossible for a surgeon to grow bones at such a speed
.
This is no good. Well, Kimura-san said
that it's easier to make by experiencing his own remodeling, but I think he
just wants to play.
If you feel like that often, you'll be weakened and die even if you don't
fight.
Is it okay to eat?
I understand that I want to get rid of it like before, but
ah, even if the ideal is like this, if you actually do it like that, the wound of the liquor will become bigger,
so it's different from what I thought I could only serve a
little.  It seems that you found it-it
's certainly a romance that the jacket weapon comes out of the body, but
if it's not good to keep it, I'd like to proceed and make it flashy.
How is it?